[Music]
well
oscar-winner cate blanchett also has
plenty to celebrate she's the first
female villain ever in a Marvel movie
she's in for Ragnarok it's out November
3rd and as I found out she wasn't
intimidated her co-star is this true you
are the first female villain in the
Marvel Universe in Marvel history yes
doesn't sound right that's true when I
got on set and we think it's taken this
long to catch up oh this would you have
the handle goddess of death people tend
not to want to mess with you the goddess
of death is invaded Asgard
some of the happiest times have been
feeding people out I've really enjoyed
us I don't speak today I can just throw
axes into someone's gut
and she can manifest weapons from many
parts of her body
I thought you'd be glad to see me in
Kate's crosshairs Thor and the hall how
is it adding someone like Kate Blanchet
to this cast I'm amazing it makes us so
much cooler either you call that the
contact hi I kind of stand near a
certain person you get kind of lifted
kneel before your queen do you get huge
cool points at home look yeah definitely
my daughter was her first experience of
being on set with me so she thinks that
that's what I do all the time she thinks
acting is manifesting weapons out of
your hands and killing people
are you now are you now the toughest
person in your household always have
been
[Music]
you